Das Witzall, unendliche Weiten des Humors, ein Kosmos der Anekdoten, die Besatzung des Podcast-UFO, Florentin Will an der Gag-Kanone und Käpt'n Stefan Tietze sind seit nunmehr als sechseinhalb Jahren unterwegs, auf der Suche nach der Zielgruppe für Massagestühle. Werden Stephans Fehlkäufe der Crew zum Verhängnis werden? Werden noch mehr Fakten ans Licht kommen, welche die einstige Coolheit der Dinosaurier sukzessive zerstört? Werden sie zurück auf den Boden der Tatsachen kommen, bevor das Kratzeis zuneige geht?
Vielleicht finden wir die Antworten in den Kosmos erneut. Mir gegenüber sitzt natürlich der einzigartige Stefan Titzmann. Und mir schräg gegenüber sitzt Florentin Wild. Ja, wir werden immer enger. Ja, wir sitzen enger. Ich komme in diesen Raum, Florentin hat hier ein bisschen dekoriert. Also ich habe das Gefühl, dieser Raum wird langsam auch verschwinden. Irgendwann, glaube ich, passt mein Schlüssel nicht mehr. Wir müssen uns was Neues überlegen. Nein, ich habe gehört, dass das für die Audioqualität gut ist, wenn man Möbel, viele Möbel reinpackt in so einen Raum, die den Ton schlucken, der soll weg, der gehört ja uns, die Leute, die alle vor dem Haus warten und den Podcast illegal kostenlos konsumieren wollen, sollen ja abgeschreckt werden. These, ich glaube, niemand weiß, wie Ton funktioniert, wie Tonaufnahme funktioniert, wie Mikrofone funktionieren, niemand weiß, wie Ohren genau funktionieren, ich glaube, das ist so eine Gruppe von Menschen, die irgendwie clever genug waren, so eine Nische zu finden, wo sie jetzt behaupten, wo sie mit ihrem Grenzwissen jetzt meinen, irgendwie Position einzunehmen und sowas, wo aber die einfach nur clever waren und waren die Ersten, die gesagt haben, so funktioniert es. Aber auch keine Ahnung. Ich glaube, auch wenn du so Akustik studierst oder so, erster Tag, der Professor macht so ganz leise die Tür zu. Okay, herzlich willkommen an der Uni. Er macht erst noch so einen Test, dass keiner, dass keiner ein Eindringlinge in der Brille ist. Er haut den so vor die Augen, ob sie die Augen offen haben. Nur wenn sie alle die Augen offen haben, dann fängt er an. Nur wenn alle die Augen offen haben, dann geht's los. Dann geht's los. Schön, dass ihr da seid. Das Wichtigste vorweg, wir haben keine Ahnung, wie Akustik funktioniert. Ich wusste es! Wir würden nur gerne den Lehrstuhl behalten. Also jetzt gerne die nächsten 45 Minuten Gesprächslautstärke und kurzes Auflachen. Und Dave und Kevin in der letzten Reihe high-fifen sich, weil sie darauf spekuliert haben, dass fucking Tonshit, das war jetzt das Studium, Tonshit M-A, dass das fucking nochmal das Studium ist, wo man nichts lernen muss. Nina schiebt Frank wortlos einen 10-Euro-Schein zu. Man merkt, das Gerücht hat diesen Raum bereits verlassen. Oh, und das goes Act One. Wir wissen nicht warum, weil wir nicht genau verstehen, warum man manche Wörter hört in anderen Räumen und manche nicht. Aber so ist das. Wollen wir ein Video anschauen, The Sound of Silence, hat jemand Bock? Fucking Sound of Silence, dass wir im Weltall hören, vielleicht niemand schreien. Der einzige, von dem wir wissen, dass er richtig Ahnung von Ton hat, ist der fantastische Produzent unseres tollen Intros heute. Das ist Cenax Productions. Mittlerweile sind wir schon über Privatpersonen hinausgewachsen, sondern die Intros werden von professionellen Musikproduktionen hergestellt, die mehr sind als nur ein Eigenname.
Nee, weil ich denke mir auch, also vielen Dank, auch tolle Überleitung.
CNAX Productions, richtig gut.
Aber auch so dieses, weil ich kenne von Räumen, die gut klingen, habe ich mal gehört, einfache Faustregel, die 90-Grad-Winkel sukzessive minimieren. Das hat einmal ein neues Wort gelernt im Intro. Im Intro habe ich das Wort sukzessive gelernt. Und diese Folge werde ich inflationär gebrauchen. Das habe ich in letzter Folge gelernt. Also inflationär sukzessive soll man in einem Raum die 90-Grad-Winkel runterschrauben, weil je weniger 90-Grad-Winkel, desto besser die Akustik. Also in der Kugel hat man, glaube ich, die beste Akustik. In der Zauberkugel zum Beispiel, in der Mini-Playback-Show hattest du ja die Zauberkugel, da klang alles gut. Stell dir die armen Kinder vor, die in der Zauberkugel singen und sich denken, das klingt genial, ich bin der beste, bin der neue Mick Jagger oder Heino oder wer auch immer damals krass war. Ich geh da raus und ich hau Linda Demol aus den Socken raus, aus den bunt gestreiften Socken haue ich die raus, die flattert einmal quer durchs Studio und dann gehen die raus und plötzlich klingt alles schrecklich, was sie sehen, weil sie nicht mehr in dieser Kugel sind. Zeig dir nämlich wieder mal, dass in deiner Blase klingt immer alles gut. Stark. Aber wenn du deine Blase mal verlässt, dann nicht. Entweder du legst den Stift weg oder du malst was an die Flipchart. Aber du kannst jetzt nicht stundenlang mit dem Stift gestikulieren. Stefan steht vor einer Flipchart, die blank ist. Lea? Nee, ich habe draufgeschrieben, keine Regeln. Erste Regel, keine Regeln. Zweite Regel, lustig sein. Dritte Regel, ausreden lassen. Okay. Nee, weil aus irgendeinem Grund steht dieser Raum nicht nur voll mit Tischen, wo ich nicht weiß, wo sie herkommen. Flo und den hat sich hier reingestellt. Hier steht auch noch ein Flipchart, ein Flipchart und drei Permanentmarker, blau, rot ist verschwunden, rot ist nicht da, blau, grün und schwarz haben überlebt und jetzt habe ich mir überlegt, die ganze Folge diesen Stift in der Hand zu haben und dann so sozusagen, man hat nämlich ein ganz anderes Mindset, man hat dieses Mindset von, alles was ich sage, hat gleich vielleicht den Wert, an die Tafel gebracht zu werden, an die Flipchart gebracht zu werden. Und dadurch hat man diesen ganz anderen Mindset. Man spricht ganz anders. Man spricht viel geschriebener, weil man ja denkt, oh, das könnte gleich an die Flipchart kommen, gleich könnte es wichtig werden. Und das Ziel ist gar nicht, gute Ideen zu haben, sondern nur an die Flipchart zu kommen. Wenn jemand der Kursleiter was aufschreibt an die Flipchart, dann hat man gewonnen. Ich habe den Redestift. Ich habe den Autoritätsstift. Du hast den Stift, der entscheidet, was der Nachwelt übrig gelassen ist, was auf den Rosetta Stone geklopft wird, welcher Kakadu und welcher Pharao eingraviert wird und welcher nicht und welche Ideen einfach im Sand der Geschichte verliessen. Okay, das schreibe ich nicht an die Tabel. Okay, der ist sowas durchgestrichen. Aber ist der Permanent-Marker nicht das Zepter des
des Zepter
des Büros des 21. Jahrhunderts
Menschens? Ja, das stimmt schon.
Man hat eine Menge Macht. Kann man das so
an die Tafel bringen?
Wenn alle Leute was sagen und man schreibt alles
auf, nur Paul sagt was und man
Okay, lass es einfach die nächste Runde gehen.
Nee, voll gut, genau. Einfach hier. Vielen Dank
auch an dich, Paul und so. Wir hatten übrigens mal
vor einigen Folgen das Thema, wenn man
in einer Menschengruppe rundum geht. Fällt dir jetzt ein Gag ein zu einer Folge von vor drei? Nee, da hat mir tatsächlich erst jetzt jemand was geschrieben. Du hast vor drei Folgen, da hast du mich gedisst, da meintest du, ich komme immer zu spät. Und ich wollte dir eines sagen, fick dich. Das war's von mir. Drei Wochen lang habe ich an der Antwort gearbeitet. Und ich hatte so gehofft, dass es nochmal aufkommt, aber kam es nicht. Deswegen muss ich das nochmal rausholen. Deswegen spiel ich das an. Und da ging es darum, dass man, wenn man im Kreis rum sich vorstellt, hat die Person, die als erstes spricht, eine enorme Macht, weil die einfach die Ebene festlegt. Wenn du sagst, hey, ich bin der Schnieke Stefan, dann kann dann danach nicht irgendwie nochmal jemand komplett von vorne ausholen und sagen, ich freue mich total hier zu sein, wenn du nicht gesagt hast, ich freue mich hier zu sein. Okay, das Spiel wurde nicht mal festgelegt. Weil sonst alle denken, du freust dich nicht hier zu sein. Und uns hat ein Hörer eine fantastische Anekdote geschickt, auch aus einer ähnlichen Situation, als es im Kreis rumging. Und der war als erstes dran, sich vorzustellen und hat sich vorgestellt mit, ich verfälsche den Namen jetzt, ja, hallo, ich bin Herr Schneider. Bendrick. Ich bin Bendrick Schneider und ich freue mich hier zu sein. Und die nächste Person gesagt, ja, hi, ich bin die Lisa und ich freue mich hier zu sein. Ja, ich bin der Robert und alle haben sich mit ihrem Vornamen vorgestellt. Und seitdem wieder das Bericht, dass er mega der Spießer ist. Und er hat dazu geschrieben, den Rest des Workshops haben sich alle geduzt, nur ich wurde gesiegt. Nein! Das ist perfekt! Ich fand's fantastisch. Aber was ist Nina für eine fucking Arschloch-Person? Diese zweite Person, die den einfach komplett auf dem Messer laufen lässt. Du kannst nicht sagen, ich bin Doktor Benedikt Schneider, kannst du nicht sagen, hey, ich bin die Babsi, freut euch. Yo, ich bin die Babsi, was geht, ich freue mich mega, bei euch zu sein, so krass, dass wir hier zusammenkommen und wie mein Spieservorredner gerade gesagt hat. Ja, ich finde es so gut, dass selbst der Kursleiter wird geduzt, nur Doktor Benedikt Schneider wird von allen konsequent gesiezt. Ah, das finde ich fantastisch. Ich finde es fantastisch, aber sie hat halt die Regel durchbrochen. Ja genau, das Problem ist Babsi. Weil genau, die Verantwortung, die in demjenigen liegt, der anfängt, ist ja immens. Du bist ja verantwortlich für möglicherweise die Stimmung des ganzen Jahres. Wenn du einen Gag machst, denkt der Lehrer auch schon, ja fuck, jetzt habe ich so einen Joker hier drin. Und da muss man auch einfach ein bisschen fresher und lustig sein. Deswegen bestenfalls am ersten Tag immer krank sein. Ich war am ersten Tag der Frank-Elser-Masterclass, bin ich angekommen, Berlin, dachte, es kommt das grosse Leben. Ich haue hier richtig auf die Pauke. Berlin ist meine Stadt, mein neues Leben, ich werde der neue Thomas Gottschalk krank. Erst mal erster Tag krank, verschnieft, riesiger Hufflepuff-Schal, hat erst mal schon mal auch die Szene gesetzt. Die Kleidung kann jeder selber auswählen und niemand trägt die Kleidung, der wirklich ist. Kleidung ist immer Kostüm auch. Und wenn du irgendwo hingehst und du hast den ersten Tag, dann wählst du aus, okay, ich trage jetzt dieses Poloshirt und das Coole. Und du hast den Huffle-Schaf-Pall. Genau, ich sag mal, bei der normalen Kleidung kann man sich verstellen, aber niemand verstellt sich bei seinem Schal, weil du kaufst dir nicht extra einen Schal, um falls ich mal krank bin und cool sein will. Nein, du holst den verschnieften, ungewaschenen Schal aus dem Schrank, den du auch anziehen würdest, wenn du zu Hause sitzt und bei den Jerrys isst den ganzen Tag. Und den packe ich aus und es war natürlich der Hufflepuff-Schal. Und wo man schon sagt, da kann man sich nicht verstecken. Ich kenne diese Krank-Outfits nicht. Bei mir selbst. Du meinst mit so einem Thermometer im Mund und so einem Wärmepaket. So einer Wärmflasche. Und so einem Tropf am Arm. Das stimmt schon. Und diese blasse Farbe im Gesicht von wegen, aber ich bin so, nein. Die wir für Hysterich und Schnieferinchen ausgiebig benutzt haben, diese Signalgegenstände, wo man sofort weist, ah, die sind krank. wo selbst ein vierjähriges Kind merkt, die sind krank. Diese Leute neigen dazu, sich Schals umzuwickeln, sich dick anzuziehen, über dem Pulli noch ein Sweater, über dem Hoodie noch ein Sweaty, so und es geht immer weiter. Hoodie, Sweaty, Hoodie, Sweaty, Hoodie, Sweaty, fucking Kapuzen-Pullover. So, und dann, das habe ich nie verstanden, weil ich fühle mich ja schlechter, okay, aber ich habe jetzt nicht irgendwie das Bedürfnis, mir einen Schal umzuwickeln, weil mein Hals friert. Es ist doch eher dieses, ich zeige jetzt euch, ich bin krank. Ich habe das Gefühl, manche Leute, die krank sind, finden es auch cool, krank zu sein. Absolut. Ich habe einen anderen Geisteszustand gerade als ihr. Ich bin, man stapelt auch tief, so egal was passiert, also man ist auch in einer kranken Person nicht so böse, irgendwie, ich habe das Gefühl, es ist eher ein Kostüm, dieses, da würde ich die wieder sprechen, nämlich, weil ich glaube, man packt sich diesen Layer drauf, diesen Krankheitslayer, um quasi erstmal zu sagen, so heute bin ich krank, unzurechnungsfähig und die Latte ist tief. Ja genau, weil die Leute wissen, du bist in einem Ausnahmezustand und wenn alles kreisum geht und jeder macht einen geilen Gag, Babsi macht einen coolen Gag, Roland macht einen TikTok-Tanz, irgendwie Dr. Ulrich Schneider zitiert Goethe und du kommst dran und niest zweimal, hustest und fällst vom Stuhl, dann weist jeder, hey, das ist nicht sein A-Game heute, das ist nicht der normale Standard, den wir vom Titzmann erwarten können. Aber sie kennen dich auch nur so. Sie kennen mich auch nur so, aber du kannst nur darauf aufbauen und auch besser werden am nächsten Tag. Meine These, und die können wir ja dann mal vielleicht verifizieren, falls wir es bei der Frank-Geltser-Masterclass bei den Leuten, die mitgemacht haben und dich kennengelernt haben an diesem Tag, und das war der erste Eindruck, ich glaube ja, man updatet seine Eindrücke nicht von Leuten. Ich update nicht mal meine eigenen Meinungen. Ganz oft sage ich was und denke mir, das ist gar nicht mehr meine Meinung. Das war mal meine Meinung vielleicht, aber es ist nicht mehr meine Meinung. Und man muss sich ja ab und zu mal updaten. Und ich glaube, dass sich Leute zu selten updaten. Und Leute hatten wahrscheinlich, glaube ich jetzt nach dieser These, von dir den Eindruck, der ist immer so ein bisschen kränklich. So auch nach drei Jahren, wer ist das da hinten, das ist der Florentin, der ist immer kränklich. Und das kommt dann raus, wenn man Geburtstag hat und die Leute sich überlegen, was kann man ihm schenken. Ich kriege dann immer so ein Ibuprofen zum Vic Medi-Night-Geschenk. Ich denke mir, Leute, so seht ihr mich? Das ist mein Bild von euch.
So eine Süssigartenschüssel, aber voll mit Vic Mediney und E-Boost, so ein Geschenkkorb, einfach so ein Thermometer und ein paar Pflaster und ein Verband.
Ist so okay, weil da merkt man nämlich wirklich, wie man bei anderen Leuten ankommt, wenn man Geschenke kriegt. Wenn man wirklich weiß, du kriegst irgendwie so ein Ausmalheft mit Pferden. Du denkst dir, ihr denkt, ich mag Pferde? Wo kommt das her? Da kann man aber auch Leute wirklich zerstören, wenn man ihnen Dinge schenkt, die so komplett hundert Kilometer vom Charakter entfernt sind, dass die Person denkt, also wenn du sagst so, ich bin jetzt extra nach Salzburg gefahren, um dir die grosse Packung Mozart-Kugeln zu kaufen, alles Gute zum Geburtstag und man sich denkt, wo ist es ein Gag? Ich glaube, die Gedanken sind Hilfe, Gag, ist es ein Gag? Ich glaube, es ist kein Gag. Ja. Hilfe? Ja. Salzburg, wo nicht Salzburg? Ist Salzburg sehr weit weg? Ja, ist sehr weit weg. Zugtickets Salzburg. Ja, googeln. Und dann habe ich... Warte mal, bevor ich reagiere, lass mich kurz zehn Minuten googeln. Lass mich kurz. Dann komme ich nochmal wieder und reagiere angemessen, okay? Bevor ich jetzt mit so einem, ah ja. Ja, mit so einem Blanken, genau. Kann man überall einfügen. Ja, so ein Insert Reaction Reaktion. Das mache ich mit krass. Krass ist mein Wort, wenn ich nicht zugehört habe, sage ich krass. Weil krass kann man so sagen im Sinne von, ja genau, also krass oder nice. Weil das kann man irgendwie auf alles sagen, auch wenn irgendwie was Schlimmes passiert ist und so, ja, nice. Also wie man sagt, krass passt eigentlich, nein, es passt nicht, krass passt bei allen Sachen. Wenn es gut ist, wenn es schlecht ist, irgendwie wenn man gegenüber sagt, meine Mutter ist schon gestorben oder so ein langweiliges Shit und dann sage ich krass, krass.
Wenn du sagst, ich habe gestern irgendwie mega das coole Mädel kennengelernt, dann sage ich krass.
Stefan, kannst du mir kurz mal die Flasche da hinten geben?
Krass.
Ja gut, außer jetzt bei Fragen.
Deswegen würde ich sagen, damit ihr nichts falsch macht, hier die Top 3 der Geschenke, die immer gehen. Auf Platz drei, neues Fahrrad. Bist du bescheuert? Geht immer. Ja, na klar geht das immer. Neues Haus geht auch immer. Nein, neues Haus ist zu viel. Die Leute haben ja in der Regel schon ein Haus, wenn du sie besuchst. Das ist frech, wenn du sagst, hier, ich habe euch ein neues Haus gekauft. Dann sagst du dir ein altes Haus und Scheiße, wohingegen Fahrrad. Niemand mag sein Fahrrad, niemand ist zufrieden mit seinem aktuellen Fahrrad, jeder denkt sich, oh, ich bräuchte ein neues Fahrrad. Deswegen bring so ein schönes, komm einfach zur Party und dann auch so eine Schleife drumrum, nee, pack das Fahrrad komplett ein und du musst es tragen die ganze Zeit. Wo gibt es diese Schleifen? Dein Platz drei? Auto. Niemand mag sein Auto. Ein altes Auto. Ein neues Fahrrad oder ein altes Auto. Nee, ein Geschenk, was meiner Meinung nach immer geht, ist ein schönes Buch. Das klingt doof, abgedroschen, aber ein schönes Buch. Und jetzt kommt der Clou, wie ihr das nämlich zu einem guten Geschenk macht, from good to great. Ihr schreibt auf die Seite rein, eine Widmung. Warum das Buch geschenkt wurde. Eine kleine Story. Dieses Buch habe ich mit 19 gelesen, hat mein Leben verändert, hier. Ja, aber das weiss man doch gar nicht, wenn man es überreicht. Oder sagst du, dann schlag mal auf. Nö, es ist aber auch schön, dieses, oh, ich habe dir ein Geschenk mitgebracht, und dann entdeckt diese Person das, wenn sie mal... Ja, aber sie wird es ja nicht lesen. Niemand liest Bücher, die hat mein Geschenk bekommen. Ich habe doch tatsächlich mal Rückmeldung bekommen für eine Widmung, die ich geschrieben habe. Aber nach ein paar Tagen, wo ich dachte, oh, jetzt hat die Person sich Zeit genommen, sich mal auf Sofa zu setzen, die Tee zu machen und das Buch aufzuschlagen. Und das fand ich dann schön. Ich dachte, du hast Rückmeldung bekommen, du Stefan, das Buch, das du mir geschenkt hast, das war komplett leer. Alle Seiten sind weiss. Und du so, shit, shit, ich habe das Surkamp-Notizbuch verschenkt. Ich dachte, du liest es nicht. Fuck, du hast meinen Bluff gecoilt. Ich habe die Billigvariante gekauft, in der alle Seiten leer sind. Blöd. Ich habe jetzt ein Hörbuch gehört und ich war stolz auf mich, dass ich eine Meinung zu der Qualität dieses Hörbuchs hatte. Top-Gut? Zur Qualität des Inhalts oder zur Qualität der Produktion?
Zu der Produktion habe ich tatsächlich immer eine Meinung, aber ich meine jetzt konkret den Inhalt. Ich war stolz auf mich, dass ich eine konkrete Meinung hatte zum Inhalt dieses Buchs. Willst du sie äußern? Ist das so gut? Nee, ich fand es sehr schlecht. Oh, und ohne Scheiss ist es mir, also bei Büchern, und dann dachte ich mir, warum ist mir das gerade so ein absurdes Gefühl, ein neuartiges Gefühl, was ich gegenüber einem Hörbuch gerade habe. Habe es nicht genau verstanden, habe darüber nachgedacht und dann fiel mir auf, dass ich mir nicht anmasse, eine Meinung zu Büchern, also eine schlechte Meinung zu Büchern zu haben, weil ich denke, das ist für mich auch so ein heiliges Medium. Da gibt es ein Lektorat, da gibt es ein Autoren, Autoren. Alle Buchstaben werden verwendet in der Regel. Viele Buchstaben. Also oft gute Satzzeichen, Grammatik. Und die kennen sich aus. Und da sind, wenn ich also Grammatik und Nebensätze und holy shit, Semantik, Leute. Alter, ich glaube, ich habe noch nie was schlecht gefunden, was ein Semikolon hatte. Ich würde mir nicht mal anmassen, da überhaupt drüber eine Meinung zu bilden,
wenn ich mir denke, wow, der
Auto kann Semikolon verwenden.
Das klingt jetzt albern und blöd und dusselig
und auch kindlich.
Niedlich ein bisschen.
Niedlich, aber es stimmt ja.
Im Ernst, wenn ich ein Semikolon sehe, denke ich mir,
ja gut, der hat oder sie hat
fucking Semantik begriffen,
ich nicht. Wer bin ich, dazu eine Meinung zu haben? Aber bei Büchern denke ich mir häufig, gut, das ist jetzt nicht meine Meinung vielleicht oder so. Aber ich bin halt auch dumm, ich liege falsch. Ich liege falsch. Ich habe die falsche Meinung, ich habe den falschen Geschmack. Ja, aber wenn ich jetzt ein Kinderbuch lese, denke ich mir, gut, das ist nicht für mich. Ich bin nicht die Zielgruppe, okay. So, aber ich denke mir bei Büchern nicht, das ist einfach qualitativ scheiße, weil da zu viele Menschen ja auch dahinter mitgearbeitet haben, denke ich mir so. Und dazu habe ich dann eine Meinung gehabt, dachte mir, das ist nicht gut. Platz zwei, diese Langschwimmnudeln. Diese Langschwimmnudeln, die sind immer gut. Nein, auch ein ganz schlechtes Geschenk. Nein, warum das ein super Geschenk? Damit kann man immer was anfangen, selbst wenn man nicht gerne schwimmen geht. Was macht man?
Die meisten Leute gehen gerne schwimmen. Das kann man super gebrauchen, falls man irgendwie eine Fliege ist an der Wand und man haut drauf. Ja, das stimmt. Das ist sowieso, finde ich, einer der erleuchtetsten Momente meines Lebens, weil, ich weiß nicht, ob du das kennst, du hattest wahrscheinlich nicht eine Katze, Aber es gibt die Momente, wenn an der Decke eine Fliege ist und man kommt nicht hin, die Fliege zu zerstören, vernichten, sie zu zerbersten. Und dann hebt man die Katze hoch und hebt die Katze an die Decke und die Katze fängt die Fliege. Was? Wie? Ja, wie? Und das ist genial. Wie fängt sie die Fliege? Ja, mit ihren Pfoten halt. Was meinst du denn? Fängt oder zerberstet auch? Nee, die zermalmt die.
Und da finde ich es so geil, weil da arbeiten Mensch und Tier zusammen.
Gegen Tier.
Mensch und Tier gegen Tier. Klar, gegen was denn sonst?
Allein, dass die Katze checkt, oh, meine Aufgabe ist jetzt, die Fliege zu fangen.
Weil normalerweise, wenn du eine Katze hochhebst, sind die vielleicht desorientiert, wollen wieder runter, kratzen dich, beißen dich oder quieken laut. Aber in dem Moment checkt die Katze, oh, wir arbeiten hier zusammen, hier entsteht gerade eine Symbiose. Sagst du was, Power Rangers, verschiedene Power Rangers klicken ineinander. Man morpht zusammen, man mutiert zu einem höheren Wesen die Vorteile von beiden Tieren. Das weiß ich noch nicht, es kann zumindest Fliegen kaputt machen. Ich weiß nicht, ob es ein höheres Wesen ist per se. Aber das finde ich immer spannend, dass die Katze, und du siehst ja Katze an, die strengt sich gerade richtig an, weil ich glaube, Katzen haben auch die wollen nicht versagen dann in dem Moment, weil sie sagen so, ey, du kannst doch gut Tiere fangen, jetzt bist du dran und die Katze sagt, ich liege schon viel rum sonst, also ich glaube, ich muss, ich brauche jetzt mal einen Moment. Und ihr seht nur, wenn ich Erfolg hatte, ihr seht draußen nicht die Katzen
oder die Mäuse, die ich nicht gefangen habe.
Das stimmt,
ja. Ihr wisst, ihr kennt nicht die
Mauspopulation. Also einmal im Monat
eine Maus fangen, ihr wisst nicht, wie gut das eine
Leistung ist. Die Menschen können das nicht einschätzen.
Fucking nervig, Katzen und Flipcharts.
Jetzt mit dieser Fliege,
die kann ich besiegen. So, aber
du willst mir sagen, dass du zum ersten Mal die Katze hochgehoben hast? Ja. Also erst mal, wie bist du auf die Idee gekommen? Ist das ein common phenomenon? Ja, absolut. Absolut. Katzen hochheben. Absolut, ich habe Gifs gesehen, ich habe Videos gesehen, wo Leute Katzen hochheben, um an Fliegen zu kommen, an die sie selber nicht rankommen. Und die Katze ist immer so ein I got this, ich bin bereit, ich bin bereit, dafür bin ich ausgebildet, das kann ich, das kann ich, das kann ich. Aber jede Katze? Ja klar. Da musst du so ein Special Bonding haben. Nein, jede Katze kann Fliegen fangen. Das ist wie ein Snack, das ist wie ein Buffet für die, wie ein kleiner Snack, wie so Atmosflips. Das ist halt nicht die Mahlzeit, aber so eine Fliege snacken die gerne mal weg. Aber wenn ich jetzt von einem Kumpel die Katze mal hochgehoben habe, dachte die dann, wir fangen jetzt eine Fliege oder dachte sie, an welchem Moment checkt sie, ah, this is my task now? Das ist wahrscheinlich so eine Körpersprachennummer und wenn die auch die Fliege, vielleicht hat sie die Fliege davor schon gesehen und das war so, man beäugt sich so, aber ich bin halt doch nur ein halb Meter hoch. Ich bin zu klein, ich gebe mir jetzt nicht die Blöse und versuche da in vier Meter Höhe Decke hochzuschieben. Wenn ich alleine wäre, würde ich es machen. Wenn ich alleine würde es machen, würde ich versuchen, hier auf den Schrank und dann von da und dann schönen Walljump und dann da hoch, aber wir sind immer noch da, also weiß nicht. So, und dann in dem Moment, in dem du sagst, oh, da ist eine Fliege, hebst du die hoch? Ich glaube, die kooperieren. Ich glaube, du kannst sogar eine fremde Katze hochheben und die würde kooperieren, weil sie checkt in dem Moment, wir sind gerade ein Team. Aber das müsste man jetzt mal auf die Spitze treiben. Also man müsste auch mal eine Katze oben hin in die Ecke kleben.
Falls ihr eine Katze habt, schickt sie uns
schickt sie uns in einem Karton
an 0800 555
Katze. Wir bauen
ein großes Studio auf, wo wir ganz viele
Katzen haben mit ganz vielen Fliegen.
Also ich würde auch gerne wissen,
wir brauchen Kleinfliegen,
mittlere Fliegen, grössere Fliegen,
sehr grosse Fliegen,
Fledermaus.
Ich will wissen, an welchem Punkt sagt die Katze
Aber Wir brauchen kleine Fliegen, mittlere Fliegen, grössere Fliegen, sehr grosse Fliegen, fucking Fledermaus. Ich will wissen, an welchem Punkt sagt die Katze, nee, das Leben ist mir zu wertvoll, das ist schützenswert, auch das haue ich nicht. An welchem Punkt sagt die Katze, du pass auf, ich kenne da jemanden, der kann sich darum kümmern, aber ich bin einfach nicht dein Mann gerade. Ich bin einfach nicht der Richtige, ich kenne meine Fähigkeiten und die sind hier überschritten. An welchem Punkt hebt uns die Katze hoch? Ja, genau. Um drauf zu hauen. Oder ab welchem Punkt hebt eine Katze eine andere Katze hoch? Ab welchem Punkt checken die selber, wir helfen uns hier gegenseitig? Weil wenn genug Fliegen da sind, machen wir, ich mache die erste, du machst die zweite. Ja, an welchem Punkt hebt eine Katze eine weitere Katze auf, um es outzusourcen? Ja, leg dir mal so kleine Trenchcodes hin und schau, wann die zu dritt aufeinander stehen und einen Trenchcoat haben. Das finde ich ja fantastisch. Das wusste ich gar nicht, dass man Tiere so Pokémon-artig einsetzen kann. Ja, kann man. Kann man, nur die checken das auch. Das ist schon nicht schlecht. Aber warum haben die ein Interesse daran, Fliegen zu töten? Weil die kleine Snacks sind. Essen die die dann? Ja, klar! Bis jetzt nicht erwähnt. Die sind sehr wichtigen... Kleine Snacks, ihr habt doch gesagt, die sind am Buffet. Kleiner Snack, die snacken die weg. Die snacken die weg? Und manche lassen die Flügel übrig. Manche essen die Flügel mit, manche lassen die übrig. Das ist wie so, bei manchen Menschen essen Pizza ran mit und manche ohne. Und jeder von den Parteien denkt sich, habt ihr einen Schaden, die andere Partei? Und so ist es bei Tieren auch. Manche Tiere essen die Flügel mit, andere lassen die Flü mit, andere lassen die... Keine Carbs. Ja, und andere sagt, du Banause! Das ist der beste Teil! Das ist der beste Teil! Das ist nicht racist. Leute, noch nicht. Nochmal, noch nicht. Nochmal. Das ist nicht racist. Hast du gerade etwas auf mich geschnippst? Ne, ich wollte es nicht auf dich schnippen. Entschuldigung, ich wollte es in deine generelle Richtung schnippen. Weil, weil ich dachte nämlich mal irgendwann, ah, Chamäleon, ich hole mir einen Chamäleon, weil die können, dann kann ich mit denen auf die Finger kann ich die setzen. Das geht auch, glaube ich. Die haben auch diese Lego-artigen Füsschen und Ärmchen, die können sich so auf deinen Finger setzen, super niedlich, weil die sind wie dafür gemacht, um auf menschliche Finger zu setzen, weil die haben die so drei so klauen und das passt perfekt. Und dann kann man die so in Richtung Fliege führen und dann gucken die das an, wenn man Glück hat, nehmen dabei, wenn man Glück hat, auch noch die Farbe der Wand an. Ja, die Fliege denkt sich, was kommt denn Trottel hier mit so einem Finger an und deutet auf mich, was für ein... Boah, nein! Ja, eine Zunge, und da weiß ich nicht, ob die auch die Farbe annimmt. Nein, die Zunge ist immer rot. Ja, das stimmt. Wie jetzt? Nee, die Zunge nimmt nicht die Farbe aus. Die Zunge ist einfach ein roter Pfeil aus dem Nichts. Nirwana. Ich glaube, die Zunge und die Schuhe nehmen nie die Farbe an. Die haben knallgelbe Schuhe. Die Crocs und die Zunge nehmen nicht die Farbe an. Ja, das ist das Problem. Das ist ja wie mit dem Schneebär, wo die Nase schwarz ist, der sich denkt, danke Natur, dass ich perfekt getan bin mit meinem Eisbär. Oder mittlerweile sind es vielleicht nur noch Schneebären, weil der Lebensraum immer wärmer wird. Nice! Der Effekt ist nicht nice, aber das finden wir schlecht. Das finden wir schlecht. Aber vielleicht nehmen sie eine andere Farbe an, wenn es kein Eis mehr gibt. Das ist nämlich die Frage, wann gibt es so wenig Eis, dass Eisbären Grünbären werden. Oder Grünbären, je nachdem, wo sie leben. Gut, okay. Wir werden es sehen, wir erleben das ja alles noch, wie alles schmilzt und das Wasser irgendwo anders hingeht. 1,5 Grad wird die Werde ärmer. W die Erde ärmer? Anderer Fakt. Aber der Fakt, den ich eigentlich sagen wollte, ist, wird die Erde wärmer. Wo man jetzt erst mal sagt, das klingt nicht so viel. Ja, ist aber viel, weil irgendwelche Ströme irgendwas umdrehen und dann, glaube ich, haben es vor allem auch Heissluftballons schwieriger. Weil das habe ich gelernt, je wärmer es ist, desto schwerer Heissluftballons. Ich habe immer versucht, mit einer Kindergruppe Heißluftballons zu bauen, mit dabei einer Hoffnung zu schließen. Und das Problem ist, an besonders heißen Tagen ist es schwer für einen Heißluftballon, weil der lebt ja davon, dass innerhalb des Heißluftballons es wärmer ist als außen, und je höher die Differenz, desto mehr ballert der in die Höhe, in die heilsbarriere Geschwindigkeit. Und deswegen haben die ein Riesenproblem. Und deswegen glaube ich, werden Heißluftballonbesitzer da auch wirklich in den Streik treten. Die Heißluftballon... Streik. Die Heißluftballongewerkschaft sagt, nein, wir legen die Gasflasche nieder. Und alle sagen, okay? Nee, nee, im Ernst, wir machen das. Ja, okay. Nee, jetzt mal ohne Scheiß., leg das da hin. Ihr glaubt uns das nicht, oder? Ehrlich gesagt, doch, ihr könnt das gerne machen. Okay, dann wollen wir mal schauen, wie ihr nach einer Woche ohne Heissluftballon angekrochen kommt und uns bettelt, wieder zu fliegen, okay? Jungs, wir gehen. Plot Twist, Jahrestag mit der Freundin, ich komme auf keine Idee. Weil meine einzige Idee... Die Bowlingbahn ist ausgebucht, verdammt nochmal. Bowlingbahn ist ausgebucht, weil alle Trottel, die vorher diese Heissluftballon fahrten, die muss man jetzt bowlen gehen. Shit, scheiße. Und dann gibt es so einen Streikbrecher Heissluftballon, wo ganz viele Leute dran hängen. Streikbrecher? Ja, das sind die, die beim Streik nicht mitmachen. Dass das Wort Streikbrecher Heissluftballon gerade so schnell aus dir rausgekommen ist, lässt mich in Ehrfurcht erzittern. Vielleicht arbeite ich an einem Roman. Wie heißt es? Willi, der Heißluftballon-Streikbrecher. Es ist ein Kinderbuch, aber eher für alte Kinder. Also für alte Seelen in jungen Körpern. Okay, wie weit bist du? Beim Titel. Und ich habe die Kapitel Namen. Also ich versuche mir immer so eine Struktur zu legen. Kapitel eins und dann kam Rudolf. Kapitel zwei doch das war noch nicht alles. Kapitel drei Rudolf geht eine gute Bescherung oder etwa doch nicht. Und dann weiß ich immer genau, was ich in den Kapitel ungefähr schreiben muss. Und so habe ich die gesamte Geschichte schon vorausgeplant. Völliger Nonsens, aber in meinem fällt dann schon irgendwas ein. Aber das meine ich, bei Büchern kannst du einfach, weil das Buch ist so ein selbstbewusstes Medium. Und Luhmann hat ja recht, wenn er sagt, the medium is the message. Und ehrlich gesagt, die Message eines Buchs sagt mir, fucking Selbstbewusstsein. Du liest gerade ein Buch. Ja, dieser Einband. Ja. Da hat jemand das Cover gemalt, hallo? Dann dieser Einband, dann diese vielen Seiten, die bedruckt wurden. Da kann auch kein Quatsch draufstehen. Wer bin ich denn? Ich kann Büchern gegenüber nicht sagen, also ich könnte kein Buchkritiker sein. Ich würde immer sagen, es ist ein Buch. Es ist wahnsinnig, es ist ein Buch. Wenn ich ein Buch lese, auch nach einer Seite, wird jedes Wort in dem Buch einfach nur zu Buch, Buch, Buch, Buch, Buch, du liest gerade ein Buch, du bist so schlau, du bist so schlau, hör nicht auf, schlaue Leute, hör nicht nach einer Seite auf ein Buch zu lesen, auch wenn du die Geschichte schon seit zwei Seiten nicht mehr mitbekommen hast, du musst noch mindestens 20 weitere Seiten lesen, das ist ungefähr so die Länge, die man liest. Horror-Thriller, fucking Horror-Thriller.
Aber du kannst jetzt nicht einfach aufhören, du hast eh schon nicht mehr mitbekommen, was die Geschichte ist. Blätter einfach um, Blätter um. Man kann schon zwei
Zeilen vor dem Ende der Seite umblättern.
Das geht. Blätter um.
Wenn du angesprochen wirst,
Blätter nach oben so ein Eselsohr
rein. Ja, das ist auch gut.
Oder so ein übergrosses
so ein übergrosses Lesezeichen.
Kommen wir zu Platz Nummer eins der Geschenke, die immer
gehen. Diese riesigen Schecks.
Ach so, ich habe das Lüge. So ein riesiger
Scheck. Das kommt immer gut an,
ist immer ein Lacher. Diese
Vielen Dank. Kommen wir zu Platz Nummer eins der Geschenke, die immer gehen, diese riesigen Schecks. Ach so, ich dachte so. So ein riesiger Scheck, das kommt immer gut an, ist immer ein Lacher, diese, wenn jemand so ein Turnier gewinnt oder so oder eine Preisverleihung oder so Miss Universe oder Miss Saturn oder so, dann hast du so einen riesigen Scheck für 150 Euro, wenn du den mit auf die Party bringst, ist ein garantiertes gutes Geschenk. Da sagt jeder, geil, Geld kann ich gebrauchen, ich stehe gerne in der Sparkassenschlange mit einem riesengroßen Scheck unterm Arm, das ist mein Nachmittag. Wie lösen man das ein? Ich glaube, du brauchst eine riesengroße Bank. Scheckmaschine. Einmal wurde ich mit einem Scheck bezahlt, bei irgendeinem Quatsch, irgendeinem kleiner Dreh einen Tag, und ich dachte mir, Cash, Cash, Cash, ich krieg Geld und geb's aus für Süßigkeiten. Und ich hab schon geplant, welche. Und diese Erdnuss-Drages, also es ist so wie die M&Ms, aber halt die von Aldi und Lidl, kennst du die? Die Erdnuss-Schoko-Drages. Ja, zurück zu dem Check. Und dann hab ich den Check bekommen und ich dachte mir, was ist denn jetzt los? Vor allem, ich hab erst einen Brief bekommen und dachte, da ist jetzt Bargeld drin, wie cool wäre das denn? Das ist auch so deutsch, du kriegst einen Brief und da wird der Scheck angekündigt. Save the date für den Tag, wo der Scheck kommen kann. Save the date. Da stand ich schon im Bademantel und dampfendem Kaffee, stand ich vor meiner Tür und habe gesagt, oh, Herr Postbote, Herr Doktor Schmidt, vielen, vielen Dank für diesen Scheck. Oder hatte ich einen Scheck und den kann man nur bei der Bank einlösen, wo man sein Konto hat. Und ich habe bei einer Münchner Bank mein Konto und ich konnte den Scheck nicht in Köln einlösen. Das heißt, ich musste, wenn ich das nächste Mal in München war, zur richtigen Bank hin, um da den Scheck einzulösen, um dann irgendwie das Geld gutgeschrieben zu bekommen. Wo ich mir auch gedacht habe, sag mal, gibt es nicht ein besseres System? Ich hätte Angst, dass der platzt. Dass der Check platzt. Und weißt du, warum? Weil das so ein konkretes Wort ist, was ich in Verbindung mit Checks kenne, was es so nirgendwo anders gibt. Und wenn ich genau weiß, was damit gemeint ist, ich glaube, kann ich... Ich hoffe, der platzt nicht. Das würde ich immer sagen. Ich auch. Wenn ich einen Check bekomme, würde ich sagen, ich hoffe, der platzt nicht. Wir gucken mal, wie es läuft. Wir hoffen mal beide, dass der nicht platzt. Und der Ballonfahrer-Streikbrecher sagt so, ich auch. Boy, das hoffe ich auch. Habt ihr einen Job für mich? Was können Sie denn? Also ich kann diese Heissluftflasche auf und zumachen. Aber ich kann auch so doll an etwas ziehen, dass oben eine Flamme rauskommt. Und ich kann sehr gut unangenehme Stille nach abgelehnten Heiratsanträgen aushalten, wenn es dann wieder langsam nach unten geht. Ich kann Smalltalk und Ballon fahren. In der Reihenfolge. Aber es gibt auch kein Rechtssystem im Luft. Wenn es rechts fahren, links fahren. Nee, im Sinne von jetzt, es gibt auch kein Rechtssystem im Luftfall.
Du meinst rechtsfahren, linksfahren?
Nee, im Sinne von jetzt, es gibt kein, also ich meine.
Ballonfahren.
Ich habe schon mal aber gesprochen, dass sie sich wahnsinnig unter Wert verkaufen mit Ballonfahren.
Das stimmt.
Weil sie bezwingen wirklich einfach ein Element, sie fliegen durch die Lüfte, aber sie bleiben irgendwie auf eine sympathische, naive Art bescheiden. Unnötig. Und sagen, wir fahren. Luftschifffahrer. Nein, du bist Ballonflieger, verdammt nochmal. Nein, Herbert, du bist Ballonflieger. Und jetzt geh da raus und streik. Aber stimmt, weil ich meine, die Exekutive ist ja überall. Egal, wo du bist, der lange Arm des Gesetzes kann dich am Kragen packen und dir deiner gerechten Strafe zuwenden. Das habe ich am eigenen Leib erlebt, als ich Wahlplakate abgerissen habe. Der kam mit enormer Geschwindigkeit die Wucht des Gesetzes, des StGB in mein Gesicht. Und warum? Weil die Polizei überall ist. Die haben Hunde, die haben Pferde, die haben Katzen, die hochhalten, die hauen dir die in die Fresse. Die Polizeikatzen, genau, um die Fliegen zu verhaften. Nee, die hauen dir auf die Fresse. Den verhaftet. Ich wurde ein paar Mal von der Katze gepanscht. Mitten ins Gesicht einfach. Haben die hochgehalten, ich habe, oh, das ist süssig, reingeballert. Aber die Polizei hat keine Heißluftballons. Das heißt, würdest du ein Verbrechen in der Luft begehen, hast du keine, die Polizei
hat keine Düsenjets. Die Polizei
muss ja immer angemessen reagieren.
Wenn du auf einem Fahrrad ein Verbrechen
begehst, musst du von einem
Polizisten auf einem Fahrrad verhaftet werden.
Da darf dann kein Polizeiauto hinter dir
herfahren. Das nennt man, das ist Paragraph
13-B,
Gleichheit der Fortbildungsmöglichkeit.
Genau, das Gleichgewicht der Exekutive.
Gleichgewicht der Exekutive. Deswegen müssen die auch
Vielen Dank. die herfahren. Das nennt man, das ist Paragraph 13-B, Gleichheit der Fortbildungsmöglichkeit. Das Gleichgewicht der Exekutive. Gleichgewicht der Exekutive. Deswegen müssen die auch jedes Gefährt haben. Die haben auch Segways. Wenn du auf einem Segway ein Verbrechen begehst, müssen die auf einem Segway herfahren. Kommen die mit zwei an. Oh, aber das Ding ist, alle Straftaten, die du in der Luft begehen kannst, sind gleich so schlimm, dass die Bundeswehr anrückt. Das sind die fünf Sterne bei GTA. Die Bundeswehr hat dann Heißluftballons, sie sind aber richtig gut getarnt. Sie sind so fucking gut getarnt, weil die ganz viele Chamäleons auf den Rand geklebt haben. Gar keine schlechte Idee. Gar keine schlechte Idee. Nee, das stimmt nicht, aber das Chamäleon sieht dann aus wie der Panzer, ne? Frage. Wenn man einen Chamäleon an eine Wand setzt, an so eine geblümte Tapete, wird er geblümt. Aber nicht so, machen wir uns das vor, nicht so gut geblümt wie die Wand. Ich finde, dafür, dass es ein Tier ist ... Ja, muss man aber schon mal sagen, weil Leute wie du irgendwie, keine Ahnung, ihr seht ja auch dann, ihr müsst ja auch mal ehrlich sein, ihr liebt eure Chamäleons und so, die machen schon einen mega Job und so, wir sind uns alle einig, so ist schon geil, aber deswegen meine ich, wenn du aber dann vor denen noch mal einen Chamäleon setzt, ist er ja noch schlechter ein bisschen. Ich frage mich, wie viele Chamäleon musst du hintereinander setzen, bis die Wand als solche nicht mehr erkennbar ist. Genau, wenn du so eine VHS auf eine VHS überspielst und das zehnmal machst. Ab wann wird es grisselig, ab wann wird es Chamäleon... Ab wann steht einfach ein normales random Chamäleon vor mir. Was ist die Chamäleon-Latenz? Das ist gar keine schlechte Frage. Was ist die Halbwertszeit von Chameleon? Wie viele Chameleons brauchst du, damit es sich so verwirkt? Das ist eine gute Frage eigentlich. Vor allem, wenn du so eine ganze Chameleon-Familie hast, die in einer Reihe stehen, dann sieht der eine aus wie das linkeste Material, der andere auf der rechten Seite. Und in der Mitte hast du dann so ein Spektrum. Ja, es ist ein bisschen so, wie sie zwei Spiegel voreinander stellen. Ja. Das ist deine Reaktion, wenn du in so ein
fancy Restaurant in die Toilette gehst
und da sind so Spiegel vorne und hinten
und dann machst du, brr,
mein Gehirn kann es nicht aushalten,
diesen plötzlichen
Wissensschock,
Paradoxenschock.
Was, wenn man Kamil vor den Spiegel stellt?
Tja, Krise. Existenzkrise. Oder es wird dann auch verspiegelt. Das kann auch sein. Vielleicht kann das das auch. Wie gehen Spiegel? Was sind Spiegel? Weiß man nicht. Ich habe mich gefragt, wie dick müssen, also weil sind Spiegel nur die Oberfläche oder sind Spiegel das ganze Ein-Zentimeter-Dingen, was man als Spiegel, als solchen bezeichnet? Aber Alufolie spiegelt auch leicht, ist aber ganz dünn. Aber jetzt habe ich mir dann zu Hause so einen Spiegel, den kann man so ein bisschen schieben, wie so einen großen Schrank, so einen Einbauschrank. Davor ist so eine Spiegeltür, die kann man so schieben. Und die ist dann sehr dick von der Seite, wenn man sich das so anguckt. Da dachte ich mir so, habe dem schreiener gesagt braucht man das alles er gesagt ja ist einfach ein spiegel an diese holzwand geklebt ja aber man sieht ja von der seite dass das ziemlich dick jetzt und er sagt ja ist einfach ein spiegel davor geklebt ich dachte mir ja braucht man das wie wie welcher teil vom spiegel ist tatsächlich der spiegel was davon ist spiegel und was ist nur hülle und aus wie, und jetzt alle lachen und ha, was hat der, der hat keine Ahnung von nichts, blablabla. Aber beantwortet mir die Frage mal, ernsthaft. Es sieht nämlich aus wie Glas. Und dann kommt, also es sieht aus wie ein Dick, wie Glas von der Seite aussieht. Wie dick ist der dünnste Spiegel? Das ist die Frage. Wie dick muss ein Spiegel sein, damit es ein Spiegel ist? Dann habe ich auch zum Schreiner, habe ich es nicht gesagt, aber gedacht, Sie können mir jetzt nicht erzählen, dass wenn man den hinteren Teil abfräst, dass es dann vorne schlechter oder weniger gut spiegelt. Aber das ist eine Gameshow. Du hast einen Spiegel im Studio und fräst jede Stunde einen Millimeter. Jede Stunde? Ja, jede Stunde einen Millimeter und die Kamera ist straight auf den Spiegel gerichtet. Keine Bewegung. So dass man die ganze Zeit den gelangweilten Kameramann sieht. Aber man weiss, es spiegelt noch. Guido Kanz steht hinter dem Spiegel, den sieht man aber nicht. Den sieht man nie. Den sieht man die ganze Sendung nicht. Und man hört nur die Fräse und denkt sich, wer fräst denn da? Man hört nur diesen Lachen. Der Rachbar, hallo! Und nein, das ist aus dem Fernsehen. Das ist die Gidokants-Spiegel-Fräs-Show. Ja, und jede Stunde einen Millimeter abgefräst. Und die Frage ist, ab wann kann man Gidokants sehen? Keine schlechte Frage. Das ist eine gute Show. Du hast da echt was in der Eck, glaube ich, Stefan. Und angenommen, man fräst dann runter, kommt dann irgendwann einfach, ist einfach Glas. An dem Mund ist einfach Glas. Unschweiß, ich habe keine Ahnung, was Spiegel sind. Ich weiß es auch nicht genau. Das ist eine gute Frage. Und was ist mit den Spiegeln, die man in diese Einbahnspiegel, das ist ja das allerabgefahrenste, dass das sich nicht mehr durchgesetzt hat. Warum gibt es keine Brillen mit Einbahnspiegeln? Wenn ich dir in die Augen gucke, sehe ich deine Augen, aber du siehst auch deine Augen. Ich kann meine Augen sehen. Du starrst mich an, aber du siehst deine eigenen Augen. Warum gibt es keine Brillen aus diesem Einwandsspiegel? Doch, gibt es ja. Es gibt aber halt andersrum leider. Also es gibt ja... Moment, dass du deine eigenen Augen siehst und der andere... Nein, nein, nein. Das hast du gerade beschrieben. Nee, ich habe beschrieben, dass ich dich sehe, aber du siehst auch dich, wenn du mich anschaust. Das ist ich, wie so ein Verhörspiel. Wenn ich mich sehe, sehe ich in meinen Augen.
Ja.
Aber zum Beispiel, ich kenne jemanden, sie, eine Sie,
und sie hat die schlimmste Brille der Welt.
Und jeden Sommer, ich hasse die Jahreszeit Sommer,
weil sie dann immer mit ihrer scheiße Brille um die Ecke kommt und die ist einfach von vorne verspiegelt so sehr,
dass man einfach sich selber, man sieht zweimal sich. Man redet mit ihr und man sieht sich und sie sieht aber auch mich. Das heißt, sie hat einfach einen fucking Einbandspiegel hingesetzt und ich würde es als Prank auch wirklich, wie du gerade beschrieben, muss einfach gerne mal umdrehen, die Gläser, dass sie sich sieht und ich sie auch sehe. Das ist ja wirklich furchtbar. Ja, also das ist Kacke und ich glaube, das ist der Grund, warum sie sich nicht sich nicht durchgesetzt hat. Aber das als Kontaktlinsen oder so, das ist ja schon abgefahren. Da kann man auch viel machen. Mega. Als Kontaktlinsen? Aber dazu müssen wir wieder wissen, wie dick das sein muss, das Material. Danke. Du kannst ja nicht einen 1 cm dicke Kontaktlinsen haben. Da wird es ja wirklich albern. Das sieht ja albern aus. Kannst du nicht mehr blinzeln. Flutter Karibik, Funfact. Johnny Depp hatte die ganze Zeit Kontaktlinsen drin, nicht weil er es brauchte, sondern weil er nicht blinzeln wollte die ganze Zeit, weil so viel Licht war. Also er hat Sonnenbrillen-Kontaktlinsen drin. Sonnenbrillen-Kontaktlinsen, gute Idee. Aber du kannst auch keinen abgedroschenen Karibik-Piraten spielen, der die ganze Zeit sich die Handschützen vor die Augen hält und blinzelt, weil es so hell ist. Nee, aber jetzt mach mal Jack Sparrow mit einer Geste nach. Na ja, dass sein Augen ein bisschen zusammen... Okay, gut, er hat sich keine Mühe gegeben. Er hat auf einen fiktiven Boxsack eingedroschen und kein Boxsack. Das ist nicht der... anderen Piraten. Auf was hast du eingeschlagen? Hat er nicht so einen Skandal, dass er seine Frau geschlagen hat?
Ach so, fuck you, ey.
Das habe ich nicht mitbekommen.
Das habe ich nicht.
Also ich habe es mitbekommen, aber ich habe das nicht gecheckt.
Dein satirisches Filet-Messer habe ich nicht gecheckt.
Naja, wir sind natürlich auch ein bisschen heisse Zeit.
Aber wir sind auch, wir machen Satire, aber nicht ohne danach zu fragen.
Aber hör doch, das klingt doch, oder?
Der Gegend, den ich mache, der ist auch angemessen. Der ist doch in der Alten. Ich stelle mir vor, wie ein Bömermann so ein Riesen-Bit macht über Sand und dass man da Sand braucht als wichtiges Mittel und am Ende fragt. Aber das stimmt doch, oder? Oder was, Kies. Das ist doch nicht alles. Kommen wir zum Gast. Hier ist Max Forster. Marc, Marc, Entschuldigung. Oh, jetzt kriege ich wieder tausend Hass-Mails. Jetzt wird mein E-Mail-Postfach wieder geflutet. Anmerkung zu einer Story von vor 20 Minuten. Ich habe mal mich ein bisschen ins Fettnäpfchen geritten, als ich nämlich ein Buch verliehen habe. Ich habe gesagtgelogen, ja, das habe ich auch schon gelesen, und mich haben meine Lesezeichen, die ich mir selber mache, weil ich irgendwann mal Knickereien mache, verraten. Ach so, weil die auf Seite 20 aufgehört haben. Weil die einfach aufgehört haben. Die Lesezeichen waren auf Seite 1, 2, 3, 4, 9, 10, 11, 12 bis 20 durch. Möcht du das eine Seite nach der anderen Seite? Die Lesezeichen waren so auf Seite neun, dreiundzwanzig, das war's. Ja. Und dann, wenn man genau das Buch liest und darauf achtet, wo oben diese Knicke sind, von den alten Eselsörchen, dann merkt man schon, dass ich es nicht gelesen habe. Oder an irgendeinem Punkt so in diesem Buch vertieft war, ich konnte es nicht mehr weggeben.
Oder jemand hat dir Lesezeichen geschenkt. Kann auch sein.
Das ist nicht, auf diese Ausrede bin ich nicht gekommen.
Ich bin sofort eingeknickt.
Ich habe es wiederbekommen, das Buch.
Ich bin wirklich sofort eingeknickt.
Weil ich habe das Buch wiederbekommen
mit dem Satz, das hast du aber nicht gelesen.
Ich habe es oben an den Eselzohren gesehen.
Was hast du denn eigentlich für Freunde,
verdammt nochmal? Einmal die Spiegellady,
mit der man sich kaum,
die man kaum aushält, dann die
Vielen Dank. Ich habe es oben an den Eselsohlen gesehen. Was hast du denn eigentlich für Freunde, verdammt nochmal? Einmal die Spiegellady, mit der man sich kaum, die man kaum aushält, dann die pedantischen Leute, die... Das Buch, das du mir geliehen hast, hast du aber nicht gelesen, oder? Ich habe es an den Lesezeichen gesehen. Ja, ich habe dir ein Buch geliehen, sei doch mal dankbar. Ja, ist nicht einfach. Du brauchst neue Freunde. Einfach mal Copy, Paste, neu, alles neu. Pedanto und Spiegellady werden beide, es klingt auf eine Art auch, wie so Suicide Squad ist. Die Spiegellady ist gar nicht so schlecht. Und Pedanto, ja. Spiegellig und Pedanto, also ich muss mich von denen lösen, aber ehrlich gesagt, beide Namen klingen auch nach Bösewichten, wenn ich ehrlich bin. Von daher There were red flags along the way. Ja, man kann sich seine Freunde aussuchen, sagt man ja immer. Man kann sich seine Freunde aussuchen, aber seine Feinde nicht. Oh, das stimmt. Hast du einen Feind? Ja, ja. Ja, wirklich? Nee, ich glaube, ich glaube, man selber hat Feinde. Ich glaube, die Feinde haben einen nicht. Ich glaube, die wenigsten, also diese typischen Draco Malfoy Harry Potter Feind-Konstellationen gibt es, glaube ich, nicht, wo wirklich beide, wenn sie jetzt in Diddell-Buch schreiben müssten, was ist dein grösster Feind, beide sich selber aufschreiben, weißt du? Ich glaube, ich könnte bei dir schon Leute nennen, wo ich sagen würde, die sind deine Feinde, so im Sinne von, wenn die und du in eine Sendung eingeladen werden würden, würdest du nicht hingehen. Nee, genau, weil ich die nicht mag. Ja, genau. Aber ich sage nur, echte Realitätsfeindschaften, die es in dieser Welt gibt, in der wir gerade leben, glaube ich nicht, dass die so sind wie diese ... Ach, dass sie immer beidseitig sind. Beidseitig sind wie die Harry-Potter-Feindschaft, diese Fiktionalen, die man so kennt. Weil ich glaube, man hat jemanden als Feind, aber er hat dann oder sie hat einen anderen Feind. Ja, das stimmt. Du bist nie der Feind deines Feindes. Okay, verstehe. Oder? Ja, ja, der Feind deines Feindes bist nicht du, hört man ja auch oft. Genau, sehr gut. Ja. Oder, weiß ich nicht. Krass, krass, krass. Nice, nice. Nee, Weil ich habe auf jeden Fall Leute, die ich nicht sehen möchte, die ich nicht mag, die ich beruflich hasse, wo ich sage, das ist furchtbar. Aber ich glaube nicht, dass die das auch ich glaube, die finden mich trotzdem mega. Jetzt fühlen sich auch ganz viele Leute angesprochen. Aber angenommen, eine von diesen Personen würde diese Folge jetzt hören und schreibt dir und fragt dich, bin ich dein Feind? Würdest du ehrlich antworten oder würdest du sagen, nein, ich finde dich super? Dieser Person schreibe ich ja ohne Smiley zurück. Okay. Also an alle anderen schreibe ich dann. Wenn ich frag, bin ich dein Feind, schreibst du ja. Ich schreibe auf jeden von euch ja zurück, mit aber diesem tränenden Lach-Emoji. Okay. So, bei der einen Person, die wirklich mein Feind ist, schreibe ich nur ja. Würdest du das wirklich durchziehen? Und so seht ihr da draußen durch den subtilen Hinweis, dass ihr wirklich mein Feind seid. Bitte schreibt mir nicht wirklich. Das ziehst du nicht durch. Das würdest du nicht durchziehen. Hat mal jemand zu dir gesagt, du bist mein Feind? Nee. Hat das mal irgendwer jemals gesagt? Wer hat so viel Eier hinzugehen, wo du sagen, du bist mein Feind? Was ist das Resultat dieses Gesprächs? Ich glaube, das könnte ganz cool sein. Ich glaube, so Feindschaften auch offen ansprechen. Einfach so. Aber ich glaube, ich hatte es ein paar Mal schon andersrum, dass Leute zu mir gesagt haben, du magst mich nicht, oder? Ja, das habe ich auch. Und ich so, nee, du bist mir halt nur egal. Also ohne jetzt böse zu sein. Aber ich habe also gar nicht im Sinne von, naja, das klingt jetzt vielleicht hart, aber nee, ich habe gar keinen Bezug zu dir einfach so und es kam vielleicht falsch rüber,
wenn man sich mag, dann weiss man, dass man sich mag,
aber wenn man jemanden einfach nicht kennt und nichts mit dem zu tun hat, dann kommt manchmal so
ein, du magst mich gar nicht, oder?
Also, ich habe einfach
null Meinung zu dir. Das kam schon,
aber da hätte ich natürlich auch sagen können, ja,
du bist mein größter Feind.
Du bist mein Erzfeind.
Warum, was habe ich dir angetan? Aber auch in dieser lockerleichen Stimme. Allein die Tatsache, dass du das nicht weißt, das zeigt schon, warum du mein Feind bist. Und so ging Jonathan nach Hause und überlegte ernsthaft, warum er Florentins größter Feind war. War es damals, als er ihn nach einem Kaugummi gefragt hat und er keinen hatte? War es damals, als er ihm beim Umzug nicht geholfen hatte? Oder damals, als er ihn nicht gegrüsst hat, weil er nicht genau wusste, ob es Florentin war oder einfach nur irgendein anderer dicker Typ? Oder damals, als er ihm gesagt hatte, ha, du Fettsack mit deinem Hufflepuff-Schal, bist du wieder krank, ne? Oder als er gefragt hat, warum hast du mir so eine dumme Schwimmnudel geschenkt, damit kann doch keiner was anfangen? Oder war es damals bei diesem Ballonstreik, bei diesem unschönen Ballonstreik, wo niemand das Jahr 2021 überschattet. Überschattet alles. Der heißt so, oh, 2021, boah, der Ballonstreik. Das war echt schrecklich. Das war wirklich schrecklich. Und dann so Zeitzeigen, so Promis, so Cordula Strat, man fährt dann unten rechts rein und sagt so, ja, das damals, war das ja wirklich früh. 1971, der Ballonstreik von Sachsen. Ja, das ist hart. Ich meine, in Amerika gab es ja diesen Autorenstreik, das ja immer total spannend ist, weil wenn du irgendeine alte Serie schaust, denkst du dir, warum ist Staffel 5 so schlecht? Und dann recherchiert man und dann war das vielleicht, weil da genau der Autorenstreik war und halt irgendwelche Lichtassistenten, die dann die Drehbücher schreiben mussten. Oder bei Late-Night-Shows gibt es ja diese Conan-Phase, wo Conan lange diesen Streik hatte, wo er einfach irgendwie improvisierte Sachen gemacht hat und irgendwie sich ins Publikum gesetzt hat und einfach die Zeit abgewartet hat, weil er keine Autoren mehr hatte, was ja rückblickend eine total coole Zeit war, weil es so ein bisschen Chaos und Anarchie war. Aber das finde ich so krass, dass es so einen Zeitpunkt in der amerikanischen Unterhaltungsgeschichte gibt, wo man weiß, da war irgendwie alles weird ein Jahr lang so. Aber auch dann ärgerlich, also du musst dir schon deines Berufs sehr sicher sein, weil stell dir vor, eine Berufsgruppe ist sehr schlecht. Und bei Conan hättest du ja auch noch hinten losgehen können. Bei Conan, wenn du in der ersten Sinne sagst, alles ist viel besser, Conan funktioniert ja viel besser, ohne Autoren sind die Autoren so, na shit. Und aber ich denke mir auch so, wenn die Berufsgruppe zu, also hier so Game of Thrones und so ein Shit, wenn du da Autor bist, wenn der Beruf, den du ausführst, zu beliebt ist, kannst du auch nicht streiken. Ja, das stimmt. Weil zu viele Leute würden nachkommen und sagen, ja, ich würde es auch für weniger Geld machen. Das ist ja das Problem, wenn die Nachfrage für den Job zu groß ist, können die Leute ja nicht streiken, weil dann kommen Leute nach und sagen, ja, ich mache es für den Don. Ja, stimmt schon. Vielleicht müssen wir als Podcaster mal in den Streik treten, einfach mal wirklich alle solidarisch einfach mal wirklich auf den Tisch hauen. Einfach mal wirklich auf den Tisch hauen und sagen, ja, das ist richtig, das ist die richtige Stimmung. Ja. Und einfach mal wirklich mal sagen, nein, wir machen jetzt einfach mal zwei Monate lang keine Podcasts, wir gehen in Streik, wir streiken einfach. Ja, was wollen Sie? Für eine bessere Podcasterwelt. Mein Name ist Frederikson von der Welt. Was genau versprechen Sie sich denn von den Streiken? Wir streiken, bis das ein Ende hat. Bis was genau ein Ende hat? Sorry. Bis es aufhört. Also bis Podcaster ein besseres Leben haben in dieser Gesellschaft. Weil so geht es nicht weiter. So kann es nicht weitergehen. Eriksson, Süddeutsche Zeitung. Damit ist Ihre Frage beantwortet? Okay, gut. Ja, Eriksson. Eriksson von der Süddeutschen Zeitung. Gibt es denn, also womit sind die gerade so unzufrieden? Gibt es einen Plan? Gibt es einen Zehn-Punkte-Plan? Es gibt diverse Punkte, die wir uns vorstellen, aber alles in allem der der Grand wie sagt man die, oh Gott, Moment, warum, diese you know the grand how do you say? the grand Budapest Hotel, yes, the grand scheme, the grand idea, the grand Budapest Hotel, so to say, ist im Allgemeinen schon, dass sich die Sachen bessern müssen. Danke für Ihre Frage. Davidson. Wir nehmen noch eine Frage, ja. Davidson von der neuen deutschen Welt. Ja. Was hat das für Konsequenzen für Deutschland? Hart. Beinhart. Vielen Dank. Dankeschön. Wir sehen uns nächste Woche, wenn der Streik dann noch läuft. Wir hoffen ja nicht. Wir hoffen, dass er so schnell es geht aufhören kann. Ciao, macht's gut. Ich bin morgen vom Bahnstreik betroffen. Oh ja. Und sehr wütend, dass ich nicht von A nach B komme, sondern bei A verweilen muss. Wo ich nicht hin, ich wollte nach B, aber jetzt muss ich bei A. Ja, der wollte nach B. Ich hing auch im Bahnsteig drin, beim letzten in der Herfahrt, und es war die schlimmste Bahnfahrt meines Lebens. Bei Herford? Nein, als ich hergefahren bin. Nicht zurück, sondern her. Die Hinfahrt. Die Hinfahrt, ja, gut. Und es war die schlimmste Bahnfahrt des Lebens. Moment, das ist nicht trivial. Hin, her. Hin und her. Nee, her ist so, wenn man nicht beteiligt ist. Wenn du zwei Personen siehst, dann gehen die einher. Ja. Da wird hergegangen. Ja, aber die Frage ist. Wenn du herkommst, ach so. Ja, aber wenn man so oft hin und her gefahrt, angenommen du pendelst, dann gibt es kein hin und kein her. Nee, da hast du schon recht. Wenn man an Punkt A noch ist, will man nach B, dann ist es die, dann wäre das, wenn man kommt mal jemand zurück, dann ist es die Hinfahrt. Ja. Wenn man aber schon in Punkt B ist und berichtet von der Hinfahrt, ist eigentlich die Herfahrt. Weil man ist ja hergekommen. Genau, ja. Man ist nicht hingekommen. Man ist hergekommen. Aber dein lächerlich naives A-B-Konzept scheitert ja an der Realität. Die Realität ist ja nicht so einfach. Nee, da ist es dann Bonn und Hamburg, aber ist doch scheißegal. Ja, aber man kann ja nicht sagen, ist Bon A oder ist Bon B. So einfach geht es ja nicht, wie du dir das in deiner Fantasiewelt vorstellst. Doch, je nachdem, wo du bist. Ja, aber wenn du bei B bist, ist A B und B A. Das ist ja egal. Wenn du in Bonn bist und du willst nach Bonn kommen. Nach Aachen. Sag mal, du willst von Bonn nach Aachen. Das hilft uns jetzt nicht so richtig. Ehrlich gesagt, wenn du also ich wollte dir da gerade nur zustimmen. Du hast recht gehabt. Amy willst du Bob. Und Amy wohnt in Bonn und Bob wohnt in Aachen. Ich kannte nur den Begriff Hinfahrt mein Leben lang. Hin und Rückfahrt. Aber wenn ich angekommen bin, ist es die Herfahrt, weil ich bin ja da.
Ich bin ja nicht wieder, ich bin ja hingekommen.
Also du musst ja wissen, wo du bist und wo du,
es ist schwierig. Du musst wissen, wo du bist.
Aber die Fahrt war auf jeden Fall eine Katastrophe. Ich habe das
schon mal erzählt, dass ich irgendwo im ICE
saß und die beunruhigende Durchsage kam,
wir sind zu schwer.
Ich schaue jetzt niemanden an,
aber
unser Zug ist zu schwer, wir können nicht fahren.
Und das hatte ich beim Streik auch, weil beim Streik
sind ja die meisten Züge ausgefallen, aber ein paar
und es niemanden an, aber unser Zug ist zu schwer, wir können nicht fahren. Und das hatte ich beim Streik auch, weil beim Streik sind ja die meisten Züge ausgefallen, aber ein paar sind noch gefahren und natürlich wollten alle in diese Züge rein. Und es war dann so, dass der Zug völlig überfüllt war und dann kam die Durchsage, der Zug ist zu voll, wenn nicht Leute aussteigen, können wir nicht fahren. Das ist so ein Joker-Szenario, ne? Es ist das Joker, es ist das Dark-Nightzenario. Und es ist wirklich interessant, weil es wird plötzlich zu so einer Sozialstudie. The Purge. Es wird zu The Purge, weil man wirklich so abrechnet, ich will nicht der Trottel sein, der aussteigt. Aber ich will auch nicht, dass es nicht weitergeht. Aber wenn einer aussteigt, dann sagen so Leute, er ist ein richtiger Held. Er ist ein Held. Ja, es kam, kein Witz, es kam wirklich zu Applaus. Nein, oh Gott, das ist das Unangenehmste. Es sind Leute ausgestiegen und dann hieß es wieder, vielen Dank an alle, die ausgestiegen sind, sie kriegen Gutschein, aber wir sind leider immer noch zu voll, es müssen noch mehr Leute aussteigen. Und wir haben da schon eine Stunde gewartet am Bahnhof und es war wirklich so, und das Interessante ist, wie die Dynamik sich zwischen den Fahrgästen entwickelt hat. Weil erst ist die Dynamik wir gegen die da oben. Die Scheißbahn, warum streiken die, warum organisieren die das nicht besser. Aber im Laufe der Zeit wendet sich die Aggression immer mehr auf seinen Nebenmann. Es ist die zwölf geschworen. Ja, genau. Du hast irgendwann akzeptiert, dass die Bahn Scheiße gebaut hat oder irgendwie der
Buhmann ist, aber ja, ich meine,
ich finde schon, und dann fangen Leute wirklich so an zu
sagen, ja, ich weiß nicht, wenn man keine Reservierung
hat, dann kann man ja schon
aussteigen. Es beginnt so ein Klassenstreit.
Ja, es beginnt ein Klassenstreit. Vor allem als erste Klasse,
wenn ich in der ersten Klasse sitzen würde, würde ich erst mal
sagen, so einfach bleiben wir hier sitzen.
Wir haben mehr bezahlt als die in der zweiten Klasse. Und sofort tun sich die Linien auf. Es gibt die, die reserviert haben, die, die nicht reserviert haben. Es gibt die, die einen Sitzplatz haben und es gibt die, die keinen Sitzplatz haben. Und es gibt irgendwann Diskussionen zwischen Leuten, es gibt die, die den fucking Fahrrad noch dabei haben. Und es entwickelt sich wirklich zu einem Sozialdrama. Was hat mein Fahrrad damit zu tun? Ja, du musst doch nicht... Sie meinen gerade, der hat sein Fahrrad dabei. Was hat das das bedeutend? Sie wissen doch, dass heute die Bahn streikt. Da müssen Sie doch nicht mit Ihrer Fahrradtour irgendwie in die Okamark fahren und Platz wegnehmen mit ihrem riesigen Rad. Nochmal, die Heissluftballons streiken. Ja, aber wir streiken seit zwei Monaten, das wissen Sie doch mittlerweile. Das ist doch überall in den Nachrichten. Ja, jeden Tag hören wir es.
Ich konnte schon gar nicht mehr hören.
Nee, aber das ist ja super interessant.
Das ist doch mal ein Kurzfilm eigentlich.
So ein Abteil,
Waggon 37,
versucht herauszufinden, wer das schwächste
Glied ist. Du hast dann die verschiedenen
Figuren, du hast dann die Mutter, die sagt,
ja, ich habe zwar nicht reserviert, aber wir können jetzt
mit den Kindern aufsteigen. Und eine ganz wichtige
Rolle spielen tatsächlich Kinder
in der Dynamik, weil niemand spricht
und Du hast dann die Mutter, die sagt, ja, ich habe zwar nicht reserviert, aber wir können jetzt mit den Kindern aufsteigen. Und eine ganz wichtige Rolle spielen tatsächlich Kinder in der Dynamik, weil niemand spricht irgendwas an, niemand sagt, die sollen aussteigen. Aber irgendwann sagt ein Kind, ja, warum steigen denn nicht einfach alle aus, die keine Reservierung haben? Und das Kind traut sich, das auszusprechen, weil es keine moralische Hemmung hat. Und alle Erwachsenen dann plötzlich, ja, stimmt, ja, und stimmen dem zu. Sagen viel zu schnell, ja, ja, ja, stimmt. Und alle ohne Reservierung so, ja, ja, und es ist richtig angespannt. Und irgendwann war es dann tatsächlich so, weil es ist immer mehr Zeit vergangen. Aber hat sich so eine Han Solo-Figur herausgetan, so eine Figur, die sich so hervorgetan hat als Leader der Gruppe? Ne, das nicht. Aber irgendwann sind genug Leute ausgestiegen und wir sind endlich losgefahren, fahren in den nächsten Bahnhof ein, der voll voll ist, es steigen wieder Leute ein und es kommt wieder die Durchsage. Wenn nicht Leute aussteigen, fahren wir nicht weiter. Aber an diesem Punkt hätte die Bahn doch einfach sagen können, wir halten nicht mehr an. Ich weiss nicht, ob das geht, weil wir alle haben gesagt, warum lasst du überhaupt noch Leute einsteigen?
Plötzlich waren die, die noch eingestiegen sind, die Leute.
Die sind die Buhmänner.
Wo man sich fragt, warum, also nur weil jetzt du schon länger drin sitzt, warum hast du jetzt ein Vorrecht, also auch alles schön. Nee, nee, weil die hier noch an Punkt A sind, die sind dann noch her. Das sind die A-Leute, nicht die B, wir sind die A-Leute, wir wollen nicht die B-Leute hier drin haben. Nee, die wollen noch wohin, ihr kommt woher. Verstehst du, was ich meine? Ich verstehe, was du meinst. Ja, aber du kannst doch dein Fahrrad einfach, wenn du mit deinem Fahrrad aussteigst, können zwei neue Leute rein. Nochmal, lassen Sie mich mit meinem packen Fahrrad. Und es war wirklich die absolute Katastrophe, weil es war zwischenmenschlich wirklich anstrengend, diese konstante Anspannung, dieses steig du aus, steig ich aus, soll ich aussteigen, soll ich jetzt der sein, der ist los, weil ich hatte ein Hotel am anderen Ort, ich konnte nirgendwo hin, niemand konnte irgendwo hin. Ich hätte mich so unangenehm, als der Lieder etablieren wollen dann, er hätte dann irgendwann so aufgestanden und gesagt, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, die Bogen schlagen hoch. Ich möchte jetzt jedem, alle stellen mal kurz auf. Ich stehe ja schon. Alle, die stehen. Seit Aachen. Wir wollen noch bis nach Bonn. Ja, okay. Von Aachen nach Bonn. Ich will nach Chemnitz. Da kommen wir her. So, aber alle, die heute Abend einen Termin haben, setzen sich hin. Alle, die jetzt noch stehen, steigen bitte aus. Das hätte ich gesagt. Und ich hätte auch vergessen, dass ich mich auch hätte hinsetzen müssen. Und oh fuck. Du musst der Erste sein, der aussteigt. Ganz ehrlich, Stress oder ein Termin ist doch der wichtigste Grund. Es war ein absolutes Trauma und es war irgendwann an dem Punkt, dass wir so viel Verspätung hatten, dass es eigentlich auch egal war. Und alle haben schon immer geguckt auf ihrem Handy, Mietwagen, irgendwas, sämtliche Mietwägen im Umkreis des Bahnhofs waren alle ausgebucht, die haben auch geguckt, weil alle hatten ja dieselbe Idee, alle Hotels waren überall ausgebucht, irgendwie, die konnten es nicht mehr machen, du hast keine Chance mehr, dieser Zug war das einzige, was du noch hattest. Und vor allem dieses soziale Drama, dass wir müssen jetzt und wir haben bei jedem Haltestelle mindestens 40 Minuten gewartet, bis genug Leute ausgestiegen sind. Und dann fahren wir eine halbe Stunde und genau das nächste Drama wieder am selben Bahnhof. Und jedes Mal, das war wirklich, wirklich... Wie lange bist du insgesamt unterwegs gewesen? Ich glaube, ich bin über zehn Stunden gefahren. Und war das Hamburg-Köln? Nee, das war nach München. Also das war schon eine lange Zugfahrt, ich glaube das war so fünfeinhalb oder sechs Stunden und insgesamt über zehn. Das ist einfach grauenvoll. Das klingt einfach grauenvoll. Das bin ich gefangen. Ich kenne dich ja mit deinen grossen Kopfhörern am Ohr. An welchem Punkt hast du die abgenommen? Nee, nie. Ich habe noch zweites Paar aufgesetzt, um möglichst leise zu sein.
Und ich habe ja genug Videos dabei, mir ist das ja egal. Aber jetzt wird es schwierig, weil wenn du Noise-Canceling auf, Noise-Gelenze in Reihe schaltest, hörst du wieder was, glaube ich. Das ist das Chamäleum-Problem so ein bisschen. Ja, das stimmt schon. Mir wurde jetzt gestern gesagt... Deswegen halte ich fern von Streikfahrten. Lass es, es ist nicht wert. Du denkst, du bist schlau und du fährst, wo niemand fährt, aber du bist nicht schlau. Niemand ist schlau. Nee, aber das, ja, die haben einfach, die haben uns eine Hand. Ja. Ich habe gestern gehört, dass Noise-Canceling ist, nur in der gleichen Lautstärke kriegt man die Anti-Welle aufs Ohr geballert. Also wenn ich lautere Geräusche ausschalten will, muss ich auch die Kopfhörer lauter machen? Nein, wenn du Baustellenlärm ausgeliefert bist, kriegst du maximal viel Lärm auf deine Ohren. Oh. Aber in der Antifrequenz von dem Baustellenlärm, damit du es nicht mehr hörst. Ja. Das ist doch Quatsch, oder? Jetzt werde ich doch einfach auch offen, einfach angelogen von meinen Nächsten. Ja, aber Antilärm ist doch dann insgesamt weniger Lärm, oder? Fucking Spiegellady, Pedanto und Lügenmann sind jetzt in meinem Leben und sag mir, wie den... Patrick will ich eigentlich genannt werden, Lügenmann, das war früher dann... Und Lügenmann, die sagen mir jetzt... Lügenmann, das ist ja auch nicht im Kostüm oder so, also das ist ja nicht mein Name. Ich finde, jeder Superheld gibt sich ja seinen eigenen Namen. Das war so ein großes L auf deinem Cape gehabt. Ja, aber das war für Larry. Für Levi's. Das ist Lacoste. Das ist nicht mein Name. Hat damit nichts zu tun. Also haltet euch dran, nehmt Streiks ernst, bitte auch den Heißlaufballonstreik, schaut, wie ihr sonst in die Lüfte kommt. Wir wünschen euch alles Gute, vielleicht dieses großes, vielleicht mal ein Bungee-Seil andersrum machen. Seht einfach, wie ihr von A nach B kommt. Ja. Guckt, wie ihr hinkommt, aber vergesst nicht, wo ihr herkommt. Ihr müsst auch wieder so, ja. Kann man Bungee-Seil auch unten starten und dann hochgeschnalzt werden eigentlich? Jetzt wagst du zu viel. Geht das? Dass man sagt zu einem Bungee-Jump-Mann, Bungee-Mann oder sagst du, nee, nee, ich will nicht von A nach B, ich will von B nach A. Ja, ich kann das auch nicht mehr machen, nachdem ich gehört habe, dass am Dortmunder Fernsehturm der Florian, da ist Bungee-Jumping so eine Plattform und da ist einfach jemand gestorben, weil der gegen den Turm geknallt ist. Und ich denke mir, das ist doch die erste Idee, auf die ich komme, wenn ich überlege, können wir das anbieten, von diesem Turm zu springen mit Bungee-Seil, ist doch mein erster Sicherheitsgedanke ist, ja, aber nur wenn man dann nicht gegen den Turm knallt. Und das Ergebnis war, er knallt gegen diesen Turm. Oh, das ist furchtbar. Nee, aber eigentlich auch mega tot. Ja, weiß ich nicht. Weiß ich auch nicht. Weiß ich auch nicht. Aber ich denke mir, wie können sich gewisse Images von Sachen überhaupt noch halten, wenn so viele Leute sterben? Also nichts gegen Bansch springen und so, das macht bestimmt super Spaß und nicht alle sterben. Aber zum Beispiel sowas wie Clowns, dass es überhaupt noch Clowns gibt. Es gibt Clownsschulen. Das noch nicht, weil alle haben ja mittlerweile Angst vor Clowns eigentlich. Dass es immer noch Leute gibt, die sagen, nein, ich baue darauf, dass Clowns auch Freude bringen können und nicht nur Albträume, ist nicht irgendwann der Punkt gesagt, wo sämtliche Clown-Schulen sagen, wisst ihr was, der Clown als solches ist einfach zerstört. Die Figur gibt es nicht mehr. Das ist wie wenn Santa Claus beerdigt wird, muss man einfach sagen, Clown als Figur ist einfach zu Ende. Das gibt es nicht mehr, weil Stephen King hat einfach am Baum gerüttelt und die Horror-Clown-Pranks haben den abgehackt. Ja, der It-Clown oder der Joker sind zu Clowns, was der Magier mit der Maske zu Zauberern ist. David Copperfield ist. Ja, das stimmt. Pogo der Clown, dieser Serienmörder in den USA, der sich als Clown verkleidet hat und auf Kindergeburtstagen war. So, wie kann denn danach noch jemand sagen, ja, passt schon, ich werde trotzdem Clown und werde trotzdem damit Erfolg haben. Wann sind grosse Schuhe lustig? Wann sind zu grosse Schuhe ein Lacher gewesen? In was für Zeiten ist eine rote Nase ein zu Tränen gerührtes Publikum, die sich nicht mehr einkriegen vor Lachen? Aber ich glaube, jetzt vermischst du, es gibt ja verschiedene Clown-Typen und die wollen untereinander nichts mehr mit uns zu tun haben. Ah, okay, jetzt haben wir haben wir Menge. Es gibt ja Whiteface, dann gibt's den August, August, Augustus irgendwas und dann gibt's den Jester, glaube ich. Also es gibt so verschiedene Clown-Typen. Also du als Laie sagst Clown, meinst aber vier verschiedene Dinge, die untereinander in einem brutalen Krieg stehen. Das ist wie so ein Bandenkrieg, so ein Gangkrieg, wenn sich da zwei Clowns über den Weg laufen. Ich will nur wissen, welche von denen kommen aus dem Auto? Ich glaube, Auto haben die alle drauf. Ich glaube, Auto darfst nur nicht verschiedene in ein Auto packen. Was ist Krusty denn? Krusty ist Whiteface, glaube ich. Ich weiß es nicht hundertprozentig. Und Amadeus? Amadeus und Sabrina? Das ist ein Pferd. Das ist ein Pferd. Du bist jetzt komplett falsch abgebogen. Also völlig falsch. Und Sonnenbrillen-Emoji ist ... Nee, das ist Stefan. Da hat überhaupt nichts. Wir müssen noch mal ganz von vorne. Das ist kein Clown. Gut. Nee, guckt, dass ihr von A nach B kommt. Behaltet die Streiks im Auge. Und kommt gut durch die Woche. Und lasst euch nicht pranken. Schaut mal, dass ihr diese Woche, ich habe, viele Leute haben uns geschrieben, ich habe Probleme damit, dass ich ständig geprankt werde. Leute ziehen die Hand weg, wenn ich die Hand greifen will zum Handschlag. Ich kriege Wasser ins Gesicht gespritzt. Deswegen bitte passt diese Woche mal ganz besonders auf. Passt auf. Das ist das Thema. Passt wirklich mal auf, dass ihr diese Woche nicht geprankt werdet. Schaut immer in die Ecken, wo sind die Kameras, die sind super auffällig. Prank-Vorhersage für nächste Woche bitte aufpassen. Ja, Prank-Warnung für Sachsen-Anhalt diese Woche. So, es lauern verschiedene Bananen, Furzkissen und diverse andere Dinge, warten so Pizzen, die man nicht bestellt hat, lauern in Sachsen-Anhalt und anderen Bundesländern. Und Roland Kamjowski aus der 8a in der Bregenzer Schule.
Haltet euch von dem fern.
Ja, in dieser Woche ganz besonders.
Das war die Prankvoraussage für nächste Woche.
KW, was auch immer.
Bleibt sicher.
Bleibt sicher, bleibt safe.
Lasst euch nicht pranken.
Lasst euch nicht pranken, macht's gut.
Kommt gut nach B.
Wir?
Heben ab.
It's a worsest-Generer-Production.